[MUSIC PLAYING]
RYAN BOYD: Hello, everyone.
My name is Ryan Boyd.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: And I'm
Michael Mannoochehri.
RYAN BOYD: And today,
we're here for the
Ryan and Michael Show.
Welcome back.
I think it's been awhile.
It's probably been over a month
since we've last done
the Michael and Ryan Show.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
It's been too long.
RYAN BOYD: It's been too long.
So I miss doing it.
Hopefully, you miss
watching it.
Today, we're here to talk about
sensory data collection
and BigQuery analysis.
So we're going to go through a
full data pipeline, an example
pipeline of how to get data into
the Google Cloud Platform
and then analyze it
with BigQuery.
As we said, my name is Ryan
Boyd, and this is Michael
Manoochehri, and here's our
Google+ and Twitter handles at
the bottom of the screen.
If you have any questions after
this event, feel free to
reach out to us there.
Of course, you should follow
the Google Cloud Platform
Developers Plus page as well.
And during this event, though,
if you're here live during the
event, check out the
Google Moderator.
So on the Google Developers Live
page, you should see a
Moderator embedded in there.
And check out that Moderator and
ask us any questions that
you have, and we'll take some
time to answer those questions
at the end.
In addition, today for the first
time, we're going to be
going through some of the Stack
Overflow questions from
the week, the most interesting
Stack Overflow questions.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: And if you
have some questions, we
answer questions at the
Google-BigQuery tag on Stack
Overflow, so please,
post them there.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah.
So we answer those live, but
we'll also go through some
interesting ones on the show.
All right.
So let's dive into this.
So first, we want to talk
about the pipeline, the
pipeline that we built in
order to get data into
BigQuery for analysis.
And this pipeline looks
something like this.
So we have on the left-hand side
here, this thing called
an OBD2 adapter.
OBD2 is the Onboard Diagnostics
Protocol, Version
2, and what it allows
you to do is collect
data from your car.
So I recently got a new car.
My last car was about 10 years
old, a little over 100,000
miles, and decided
to call it a day.
So I got a new car, and
I wanted to be a bit
geeky with my car.
So I wanted to get data
out of my car.
And then I figured out, how
could I incorporate this into
a work project so I can have
fun and get paid for
it at the same time?
It's always nice.
And so this OBD2 connector
allows me to do just that.
It's $15 or $20 on Amazon,
pretty cheap.
And basically, it has a
Bluetooth radio in it so that
when you collect data from your
car, you plug this into
your car, it collects data,
and using Bluetooth, it
communicates that data
over to my phone.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Ryan, I
wasn't familiar with this
until you started this project,
but is that the kind
of thing that mechanics
use for the
telemetry from the car?
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, exactly.
So the Onboard Diagnostics
Connector, I think it exists
in pretty much all modern cars,
and it's primarily used
by mechanics.
I think if you read the manual
in my car, it does warn
against using it for any
hobbyist purposes.
Don't tell my wife that.
But it is primarily
used by mechanics.
They also, in some of the other
cars, have more advanced
versions of these connectors
that allow you to
get even more data.
So this might be 40 or 50 data
points, something like that,
that it pulls out.
But it's pretty fun nonetheless,
and it allows you
to get data via Bluetooth over
to my Android phone.
I carry my Android phone with me
all the time, so I can get
data to my Android phone
over Bluetooth.
And then my Android phone has
an app running on it that
uploads that data up
to App Engine.
So it just make simple HTTPS
posts up to App Engine and
uploads all of the data
each time it's
collected from the connector.
And once the data is up in App
Engine, I have a goal to
analyze it.
I really want to crunch that
data, figure out how fast I'm
going, things like that.
So for that, I use Google
BigQuery, of course.
And so I need a way to get the
data from App Engine to
BigQuery, which we're going to
talk about here shortly.
One of the other things that
I should mention here is
although I'm just collecting,
in this case, data from my
individual car, there's plenty
of different use cases here
for programmatic collection of
data from sensors, getting
them into the Google
Cloud Platform, and
analyzing them there.
So we've talked with a variety
of different companies that
have different use cases for
sensor data collection, things
like weather and other types of
data where from all around
the world, you can
have the sensors.
It uploads data through the
cloud platform, and since
Google exists all around the
world and has pretty fast
connections, that's an easy way
to upload data, and then
you're analyzing it
all in the cloud.
So I even think specifically
with this car data, there
might be great use cases out
there for fleets of vehicles
to analyze patterns of how those
vehicles are operating.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: It isn't
just vehicles, as you said.
Any kind of sensor that can make
an HTTP post to the App
Engine App can use this
kind of system.
And what I also like about this
is it's so accessible.
I mean, the device you were
using to collect data from
your car was rather cheap.
You already have a phone and
with Bluetooth, and it's
something a lot of people
can do and actually code
themselves.
RYAN BOYD: All right.
So this is the complete
pipeline.
Let us know if you've built--
you can post something in the
Moderator or reach out to us in
Google+ if you've built a
similar pipeline for
your own data.
And we're definitely interested
in hearing what
you've built.
So let's talk about now the
application that we're using
for the collection of data.
So the application that we're
using right now to collect the
data is called Torque.
We're using the paid version of
this app called Torque Pro.
Here's the screenshot
from the Play Store.
And what we're doing, this
app basically does a
whole bunch of stuff.
It's written by this gentleman
named Ian Hawkins, looks like
he's put a lot of time and
energy into building an
awesome map here.
You can see here, over
100,000 downloads.
He basically does a lot of
displays and all, so you can
use this as sort of your
dashboard as you're driving.
But for my case, I really
just wanted the data.
I wanted the data out
of the application
and up to App Engine.
So it also has a way that you
can specify a HTTPS URL to App
Engine, and it just does very
simple posts over to App
Engine when each data
point is collected.
So from there, we have a very
simple App Engine app we
wrote, something like a
15-minute App Engine app--
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Very simple.
RYAN BOYD: --that takes this
data over the post variables
and just creates entries
in our Data Store.
So very simple code to write,
probably 20 lines or not much
more than that.
And we get all the data into the
App Engine Data Store, and
it looks something like this.
This may be a little small for
you to read, but we have data
like the air temperature, the
altitude, which the device
actually collects from the GPS
in my phone, the altitude,
latitude, and longitude.
We also have the RPMs, how fast
the engine is going, the
speed of the car, throttle
position, the time, all sorts
of interesting bits of data.
And you can configure
what types of
data you want to upload.
There's plenty more properties
available.
But we get this into the App
Engine data store, and the App
Engine Data Store is a great
place to collect this data and
maybe build a simple web
front end on top of it.
But if we want to do analysis,
let's say we're extending this
beyond just my car, and we want
to do an analysis on a
fleet of 10,000 cars or
something like that, we really
need the power of something
like BigQuery.
So we want to get this
data into BigQuery.
So how do we do that?
Well, there's a Trusted Tester
feature, which we'll give you
a URL here shortly that allows
you to sign up or apply to be
in this Trusted Tester
program.
But this Trusted Tester feature
allows you to get data
from the App Engine Data Store
over to BigQuery by doing a
backup of the Data Store
and storing that
backup on Cloud Storage.
That's the first step.
It's really a simple
two-step process.
So the first step is backing
up that data.
We can see here I specified my
Cloud Storage bucket called
Car Data and said that I'm doing
it on Cloud Storage.
And let me just talk a little
bit about the permission
system here quickly, because
Michael has been asking me
about this, how that works.
The permission system
is really simple.
App Engine has a application
identifier role account that
the App Engine app runs under,
and you can find that-- is it
the Application Info tab or
something like that in the App
Engine console?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: There's
an Application Settings tab
that has all this information.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, and so you grab
that email address, and
you can put that account
into a project.
So we went over to the API's
console and set the project to
be writable by that particular
email address, and that's how
we granted the permissions.
You can certainly do that also
within BigQuery as well, and
within the Cloud Storage.
They all have the same
way of doing
permissioning on these accounts.
It looks like a regular
user account.
So we gave permission for the
App Engine app to write to
Cloud Storage this bucket
called Car Data.
And then if we go over to Cloud
Storage after we do the
backup, we can see all
the backup files
within Cloud Storage.
So we see here at the
top, there's this
TorqueData.backup Info.
The Torque Data is the name of
our entity in the Data Store,
and the Backup Info file is kind
of the metadata file that
describes my backup.
I then take that, and I point
BigQuery at the Cloud Storage
URL for that Backup Info file,
and just tell BigQuery to
import that table from
Cloud Storage.
So this is showing the
UI way of doing it.
We can also programmatically
do all of this.
So you could programmatically
schedule cron jobs to allow
you to back up the data on a
scheduled time period, and you
basically are just putting in
the different parameters that
you would put into the UI in
your cron job as parameters
when you call out to
make the backups.
And in addition to that, then
of course, programmatically,
you could also import
this data from Cloud
Storage into BigQuery.
But that's the basic
steps here.
So all we have to do is get the
data into the App Engine
Data Store, get the data backed
up from the Data Store
over to Cloud Storage,
and then BigQuery
imports it from there.
And of course, we're going to
try to make this a smoother
process for you as well, but it
is really simple, two-click
process that you can do, and
then automate using the cron
job feature.
So if you you're actually
interested in testing out this
feature, the feature that allows
you to move data from
the App Engine Data Store
over to BigQuery.
You can see this URL here.
I'm going to leave this
up for a moment.
This allows you to apply for
the Trusted Tester Program.
We're looking for people who
have some interesting data in
App Engine and are looking
to analyze that data for
large-scale aggregate queries
and ad-hoc queries on that
data in BigQuery.
We have some interesting people
that have signed up so
far and have used it for a
wide variety of different
types of data, but we're always
looking for more to get
more and more of
your feedback.
All right.
So we've talked about how we
get the data into BigQuery.
Now, let's talk about actually
querying the data.
The interesting part isn't
getting the data there.
It's actually running
some queries.
So I'm going to show you
a couple queries
here that we've run.
The first query is
looking at--
and I made this a little bit
large, it looks like, but
looking at the average speed
that I drive in San Francisco.
So we can see here, rounding the
average speed, it's stored
in kilometers per hour, and then
we're converting it to
miles per hour.
And we're doing it from our
latest dump, which is on 2012,
12/03, which I think is today.
And then if I can scroll down
here a little bit, we're
looking at the particular
latitude and the particular
longitude for the query.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So this is
a bounding box around San
Francisco roughly, right?
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, this
is a bounding
box around San Francisco.
So I wanted to see when I'm
in the city, how fast am I
driving in the city?
And I think that varies a little
bit from when I'm on
the highway.
So let's query here.
And we can see here, my average
speed in the city is
47 miles per hour.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: That's
pretty fast, Ryan.
What have you been doing?
RYAN BOYD: So I don't
drive that fast,
Michael, on city streets.
I think the speed limit on city
streets is 25 or 30 miles
an hour on most of
the city streets.
So I don't drive at
47 miles an hour.
But we do have highways in the
city that go on and off of the
Bay Bridge as well as go
down to the peninsula.
So that must have been my
speed on the highway.
I will swear to that.
But now, what is my speed when
I'm outside of San Francisco?
If I'm not looking at the
bounding box for San
Francisco, how fast
am I going?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So
San Francisco is a
pretty dense city.
When you get out of the city,
you expect to probably go a
little faster because you're
on the highway.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, probably.
Let's take a look at
what this speed is.
All right.
So here we have average speed
on the peninsula, which is
doing a similar thing.
But then we basically have
different latitude and
longitudes here.
And we're not seeing this on
the screen, but I'm also
filtering out those times where
the car miscalculated my
speed and thought that I was
over the speed limit, because
that doesn't actually happen.
So I'm filtering those out.
Let's see how fast
I'm going here.
All right.
So we went from 47 miles
an hour to 54,
a little bit faster.
Not as fast as I would think,
as much faster as I would
think, and I think that's
probably because of mornings
like this morning where we're
crawling at 10 miles an hour.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: I'm
surprised you could go that
fast on the 101.
I happen to know you try to
beat rush hour, though.
RYAN BOYD: Anyway, but these are
the types of queries that
you could run, and you could
also run all sorts of other
queries on the RPMs and figuring
out what your speed
was at various RPMs and things
like that, figure out how well
your car is running.
But imagine if you're running
it not just on my 100,000
records I think I have here,
but you're running it on a
much larger data set of a car
that drives much more often
and maybe a whole fleet of
10,000, 20,000 cars.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Imagine
what you can do with this you
can find anomalies
in your fleet.
And this doesn't just
have to be cars.
It could be sensors of
any kind, right?
Imagine if you have it on
servers, and you're looking at
logs, and you want to find
anomalies in those logs.
I mean, you can do that with
BigQuery using Data Store for
what it's good at, which is
being highly available and
very high performance to rapidly
collect data, and then
using BigQuery to actually do
aggregate queries over that
Data Store data.
RYAN BOYD: So right now, we're
actually collecting this data
through this Torque application
that we talked about.
We do actually have this
goal of using other
parts of the platform.
I'm going to just skip
back here quickly
to the diagram here.
So we have this goal of on the
Android phone using the Cloud
Endpoints feature that we
announced at Google I/O. And
the Cloud Endpoints feature
allows you to use our API
infrastructure in order
to have APIs for your
applications.
And it's particularly valuable
in the mobile use cases.
So imagine here if I'm able
to get the data from the
Bluetooth sensor directly, write
my own application, and
upload it to App Engine.
I have a little bit more
control over it then.
And what I mean by control is
right now, the application--
which is awesome--
that's running on my phone, this
Torque application, that
application is collecting data
points a few times every
second, and for each of those
few times every second, is
making a request over to
my App Engine app and
posting that data.
But with the Cloud Endpoints
implementation, what I could
do is actually use the Batch
functionality, or just batch
them up myself manually,
and post 10 or 20
of these at a time.
And so basically, not have to
make a few HTTP requests every
second, but rather once
every 10 seconds or
something like that.
So we can optimize
it a little bit.
And then that that'll be a great
example, once we're able
to do that to demonstrate how
you might collect other sensor
data from your phone or other
wireless devices and upload it
to App Engine, and then
eventually to BigQuery for
analysis, of course.
All right.
So let me--
whoops!
Let me start down here.
Apparently, I clicked a bit
of the wrong button.
Michael.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So we're
going to do something a little
bit different today.
We're going to look at some of
the great community questions
from our Stack Overflow tag,
which, as I said earlier, was
Google-BigQuery.
So Ryan, myself, members of the
BigQuery Engineering Team
read every single question.
We take your developer feedback
very seriously.
And we love the thriving
developer community that's
growing up on Stack Overflow
in relation to BigQuery.
So I'm going to read some of my
favorite questions from the
past week and actually talk
to people about them.
I think they're very useful
questions for everybody
developing with BigQuery.
And so let's just
dive into it.
The first question that got my
attention was, is it possible
to join Cloud SQL tables
to a BigQuery table?
So the answer is,
not directly.
So Cloud SQL is basically a
MySQL implementation that you
can access through Google
App Engine.
It's very powerful,
it's very useful.
But the question was, can I do a
single Select statement that
incorporates a BigQuery table
with a Cloud SQL table?
So the answer is,
not directly.
You can't write a single SQL
statement that can query both
at the same time, but you can
use the data from Cloud SQL in
a query for BigQuery.
You just need to export that
data and import it into
BigQuery, much as we described
with the App Engine Data Store
import that were talking
about earlier.
Actually, there is a way to
export data from Cloud SQL.
And the way you would do that is
export the data into a CSV
format, then import the data
back into BigQuery, and then
run your JOIN statement.
You can actually join two tables
together, and that's
basically how you do it.
We don't have a direct pipeline
like we do with the
Data Store data, but I
appreciate this feedback, and
it's something we'll definitely
look into.
RYAN BOYD: I do want to say,
though, that this is something
that you can do, not just with
Cloud SQL, but with any
relational database or other
data source you have, because
BigQuery can ingest your
data in either
CSV or a JSON format.
And we do have a lot
of customers that
BigQuery is for analysis.
We have a lot of customers
that, of course, need an
authoritative data source in a
relational database to store
their data in.
And then every now and then,
they take that data out and
put it into BigQuery, maybe in
sort of a nightly cron job
similar to how we did with
the Data Store backup.
So it's a very useful pattern
to get accustomed to.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Definitely.
And like Ryan said, if you're
using a document store, you
can use the JSON import to get
data into BigQuery, and if
you're using a relational
database, of course, CSV is a
great format for that.
So great.
So the next question I see all
the time, and I wanted to talk
a little bit about it today--
authorizing access to Google
BigQuery via API key.
So the question basically is
asking, as some Google APIs
do, can I use an API key to
authorize access to BigQuery
by basically appending a key
value to the end of a request
to the BigQuery API?
The answer is actually no.
BigQuery does not support
API key access.
But oftentimes, when you're
trying to do a request that is
something that you could use API
access for something else,
API key access, what you really
want to do is use a
service account authorization
flow.
And so we have a lot of great
documentation about how to
build this, both on an installed
application or an
App Engine application.
Basically, this gives your
application the authorization
to make calls to the BigQuery
API on your behalf.
So we have lots of
documentation
about how to do this.
But if you are interested
in using an API key type
authorization method, you
probably want to try out a
service account authorization
instead.
RYAN BOYD: And this uses a
standard OAuth 2.0 flow, and
it's the same thing with
BigQuery as with a lot of our
other APIs.
I just wanted to insert
a reminder here.
If you do have questions live,
you're listening to this live,
make sure to head out over
to our Moderator and ask
questions there.
So you can go to
developers.google.com/live,
and click on this episode, and
you'll see the embedded
Moderator there.
And we'll keep on jumping
in through some
Stack Overflow questions.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So let's
take a look at actually two
questions, but they're related,
and they're actually
from the same poster.
The first is, maximum number of
nested records and the cost
of querying those records.
Let me try to explain.
BigQuery supports two types
of data models.
One is flat records, meaning a
record with fields that are
flat, and the same for
record to record.
But we also support nested and
repeated records, meaning a
single field within
a record can have
children records as well.
So the original question was,
how many levels of nesting can
we support?
The answer is actually 100.
We support nesting
levels of 100.
And if you actually are using
a data model like this, I'd
love to see it.
I'd love to see what
you're doing.
But you can imagine how
useful that is, right?
You could actually have, for
example, a Person class, and
under that record, you could
have their age and their first
name and their last name, and
you can actually nest that.
You could even say, in this
example that I'm showing here,
the cities they lived in.
And this can be a different
amount of cities for every
single record, and it
can grow or shrink
depending on the person.
And so it's very useful,
very easy to model.
A lot of non-relational
databases already model their
data like this.
So BigQuery supports that.
So we can support up to
100 nested records.
The other question was
the cost of querying.
And so if we can skip to the
next slide, this highlights
how BigQuery actually
stores the data.
So what's really interesting
about BigQuery is we take all
of your data from row-oriented
storage, and we store it in
column-oriented storage.
And the cool thing about this
is when we have nested
records, each one of those
records gets its own column.
So for example, if we go back to
this example for the cities
that people lived in, here you
can see there's a Person
record, and underneath it, it's
the city and the years
that they lived in.
We store each of those values
in their own column.
So the cities will all get
their own column, and the
years lived will all get their
own column as well.
For BigQuery, we charge
for processing only
what you ask for.
So if you actually just want
to know, say, the average
number of years lived in any
city, and only ask for that
column, that's the only column
we're going to look at.
We're not going to touch
other children
columns in that query.
So actually, it's very
economical, and it's a very
good way to model your data.
RYAN BOYD: If you want to read
more about how we deal with
nested data in BigQuery, the
Dremel white paper actually
provides a lot of interesting
academic knowledge
of how we do that.
So look up Dremel white paper
on the web, and it describes
how this nested structure works
and how we're able to
still achieve the performance
that Michael talked about.
The one other thing we should
mention, though, in terms of
the nested data is that each of
your parent records still
needs to fit within the
64-kilobyte row limit.
So you can have, I think, 1,000
is what you said, nested
underneath it--
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: 100.
RYAN BOYD: Or 100.
But there is a limit in terms of
the amount of data that you
can have stored in there.
But if you ever get an
opportunity where you're
hitting that limit, definitely
reach out to us, and let us
know that you're hitting that
limit and allow us to take a
look, because there might be
some things that we can do,
either now or in the future,
to raise that.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Great.
So let's just check our
Moderator page and see if
there's any new questions.
There doesn't seem to be any
BigQuery questions here, but
let me refresh.
RYAN BOYD: There is one.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
There is one.
OK, this is a great question.
The question is, "Will it be
possible to import only the
chain sets of data
from App Engine?
Full Data Store dumps can be
quite large and time consuming
to perform." That's
a great question.
RYAN BOYD: So I'm curious
whether Scott has actually
been in the Trusted
Tester Program.
If you are in the Trusted Tester
Program and trying it
out, we're going to be reaching
out and looking for
your feedback soon.
Definitely send us that one
and what your use case is.
That definitely is a great
feature idea for this
functionality and something
that I would
argue for us to implement.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: I think
it's a great question.
RYAN BOYD: So that's the only
question right now.
We'll give it another second
here, if you any additional
questions on Google Moderator.
Otherwise, we'll let you
guys head home early.
I think in the West Coast here
it's four minutes before 5:00.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: It
looks like that's it.
There's no new questions
on the Moderator.
RYAN BOYD: All right.
Well, thank you everyone
for joining us today.
I'm Ryan.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
I'm Michael.
RYAN BOYD: And this is the
Ryan and Michael Show.
Take care.
[MUSIC PLAYING]